The Last Jedi may not be a film that's filled
to the brim with Easter eggs and clever secrets,
but it's full of callbacks and nods to obscure
aspects of Star Wars continuity.
We may never get the answers to some of our
most pressing questions, but at least we know
that as far as Star Wars is concerned, some
things never change.
Here a few small details you may have missed
in The Last Jedi.
Spoilers ahead.
Han's Dice
You may not have noticed them before, but
Han's golden dice finally get their moment
to shine.
These dice first appeared in A New Hope, dangling
in the cockpit of the Millennium Falcon, but
were never really seen clearly through the
rest of the trilogy.
Nevertheless, they became so legendary that
they even got their own trading card, a mention
in a few Star Wars books, and even made the
news when it came to properly rebuilding the
Millennium Falcon in The Force Awakens.
But because we've never actually seen these
things up close, it's always just been assumed
that they're, well, basic human dice.
Turns out they're covered with alien symbols
instead of pips.
Sorry, Chewie - those expensive replicas you
bought are now non-canon.
Green harvest
Luke Skywalker's love of weird colored milk
is almost a central theme of the Star Wars
saga.
When he first appears on Tatooine as a lowly
moisture farmer, he's all about the blue milk,
which comes from Banthas.
Blue milk even makes an appearance in Attack
of the Clones and Rogue One, so you can be
sure that there are strong bones across that
entire far, far away galaxy.
This time around, however, on his secluded
planet hideaway, Luke's getting into the green
stuff.
In a weirdly gratuitous milking scene, Luke
takes it upon himself to squeeze some green
milk from an anatomically horrific animal
for himself.
Breakfast of champions, Luke.
The lonely island
There's a lot going on on the island that
housed the first Jedi temple, and not a lot
of it is actually addressed in The Last Jedi.
Like, what's that weird dark side hole that
Rey is drawn into?
Luke made himself at home on the island after
Kylo Ren went berserk and burnt down Luke's
Jedi dojo.
Luke had no intention of leaving the planet,
submerging his X-Wing off the coast of his
small island home, a visual echo of what happened
to the ship on Dagobah during his own training
with Yoda.
And if there was any real question about where
Luke was going to end his journey, the answer
was in the planet's twin suns.
In a powerful callback to the moment Luke
began to realize his purpose in A New Hope,
an aging Jedi Master Luke looks over the planet's
twin suns under the same swelling John Williams
score.
Knights of Ren
The Force Awakens didn't do much to explain
Kylo Ren's band of evil weirdos.
They're seen once in a vision, hyped up in
the press surrounding The Force Awakens…
and never seen again.
One might think that Kylo Ren would have his
top dudes at his side while hunting down both
Rey and Luke, but he sticks to more military
and spiritual options instead.
But at least we kind of finally know who they
are—or were—thanks to The Last Jedi.
Kylo Ren's personal goth squad are the Jedi
from Luke's training academy, or at least
the ones who weren't killed by Kylo Ren himself.
Why did they join Kylo, and where are they
now?
We may never know.
Chop chop!
Star Wars has a well-documented love of chopping
off body parts, and why shouldn't it?
When you're swinging around laser swords that
cut through metal and rock like butter, you're
going to lose a few parts.
And no villain lost their body parts more
unceremoniously than Darth Maul, a guy poised
to be a badass villain who gets chopped in
half and thrown down a space-hole after only
a few lines of dialogue.
Maul's lines, by the way, were originally
going to be voiced by Benicio Del Toro, who
left The Phantom Menace project after most
of his dialogue was taken away.
Of course, Del Toro makes his triumphantly
weird return in The Last Jedi as DJ.
But back to being bisected by lightsabers.
Snoke's unexpected death after doing a whole
lot of showboating brings back very clear
memories of Maul.
So let's all raise a glass to Supreme Leader
Snoke; he was around, he kinda did stuff,
he was ugly, and nobody really knows who he
was.
But hey, if Darth Maul can come back with
a robot booty, anybody can.
Admiral Raddus
We know that nearly everyone who appeared
in Rogue One is dead, hero and villain alike,
and that includes Admiral Raddus, the Mon
Calamari officer of The Profundity, an iconic
ship used in the battle to get the Death Star's
plans to the rebels.
Yes, seeing a squid-headed alien at the helm
of a powerful ship was an obvious reference
to Admiral Ackbar's days of shouting "It's
a trap!" on the bridge of his own rebel ship,
but The Last Jedi took it just a little bit
deeper than that.
The cumbersomely-named Star Wars: The Last
Jedi: The Visual Dictionary reveals a ton
of information that the film never gets around
to.
One of those things is that a major ship in
the battle scenes in The Last Jedi is called
the Raddus, named as such at the behest of
Ackbar himself, in honor of the fish-face
that came before him.
Celeb cameos
Last but not least are the things that can
possibly, maybe be considered Easter eggs:
celebrity cameos.
And just like in The Force Awakens, there
are a few to watch out for.
Justin Theroux makes a very brief appearance
as the unnamed, gambling Master Codebreaker.
Meanwhile, Rogue One director Gareth Edwards
makes an appearance as a resistance fighter.
The massive army of bad guys include Game
of Thrones' Ralph Ineson as a bridge officer,
along with fellow Thrones cast-member Kate
Dickie — both joining Captain Phasma actor
Gwendoline Christie in a galaxy far, far away.
And Tom Hardy showed up as a Stormtrooper,
alongside musician Gary Barlow.
Also rumored to be hidden in the film somewhere
are Joseph Gordon-Levitt and director Edgar
Wright.
And no Star Wars film would be complete without
a Warwick Davis appearance, this time as Wodibin,
a gambler on Canto Bight.
Who else should you look for?
The cameo of Princes Harry and William, who
were NOT cut from the final film, despite
what a joke by co-star John Boyega had implied
earlier.
Quit messing around, Finn.
"Droid, please!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!